good morning everyone welcome thanks for
coming as introduction said this talk is
about testing and validating machine
learning models when deploying to
production I'm Chris and this is Solly
and today we're going to split the talk
into two sections the first section I'm
going to talk a little bit about some of
the challenges of testing validating
machine learning models on the journey
to production as well as some of the
best practices there so lay in the
second half we'll talk about some
specific techniques around this
validation and testing which you can
apply in your own companies and projects
ok let's begin so hopefully some of you
have seen this diagram before this is
from a really useful talk called hidden
technical depth in machine learning
systems it was presented by some
researchers at Google at the nips
conference back in 2015 there's a few
things to take away from this particular
diagram and the concepts from the talk
the first is that although the title of
this talk is about machine learning
models in production as soon as we start
talking about models in production we
have to think about machine learning
systems and the reason for that is if
you look at that diagram there you can
see that the machine learning code is
just that small black box component in
the middle and then there are many other
entirely necessary supporting components
that have to be considered also all
right and this is everything from
feature extraction through to monitoring
serving infrastructure there's a lot any
of these systems the second thing to
note is that there are a lot of
challenges specific to machine learning
systems so you have all the traditional
issues of software development plus data
science specific challenges around data
versioning subtle model bugs that you
can't find with traditional tests plus
just a wide range of expertise required
to understand this sort of system
varying from data science through to
engineering and DevOps ok so given these
challenges it's no surprise to see this
evolving tooling landscape particularly
around areas like data versioning model
versioning and deployment and
orchestration of deployments and you can
see a few relatively new come
or companies that are changing and
innovating in this area a lot on the
screen but this is just a small sub
sample of many others and this is a
really interesting trend to observe you
can see it as well
in big companies as they try and
especially tech companies doing a lot of
machine learning they're building these
really big frameworks for everything
from versioning through to surveying
running experiments
you've got the likes of Michelangelo at
uber tf-x at Google FPL peppy learner at
Facebook and this is a really
interesting trend to observe because
right now it's not really clear which of
these tools is going to emerge is that
the de facto go to this is and you know
what which combination of tools will
form the stack probably with the
exception of kubernetes which is your
underlying sort of lower down in the
second this is a bit further up and so
this poses a lot of questions and
challenges for you know the average
practitioner a lot of choices to make
how do we navigate this complexity a
really useful starting point is to think
about principles so there are two papers
here that I want to highlight and these
draw on experience from big tech
companies and that's a useful starting
point because they have done machine
learning and production at scale for
relatively long periods of time they've
experienced the pain the struggle and
you know a lot of times that pain
doesn't really manifest until further
down the line when it's time for
maintenance that's when that hidden
technical debt creeps in so the first
paper here is the ml test score a rubric
for ml production readiness and
technical debt reduction from Google
that came out back in 2017 this is a
really interesting paper because it
basically poses 28 quite specific tests
you can run in your own projects like a
kind of checklists you can go through
and these are specific tests for example
here's your model configuration under
version control and does it undergo a
code of view when it's updated so
specific things like that and I'd
recommend everybody here in their own
machine learning projects go through
this checklist you may find the results
a bit sobering the second paper is
software engineering for machine
learning a case study it's from some
researchers at Microsoft and it came out
see this very interesting as well
because Microsoft conducted a survey of
about 550 ml practitioners across their
business bearing from data scientists
engineers and others and they then
collated the results around okay what
are the challenges people are worried
about and what are the sorts of best
practices of a Advocate and what was
particularly interesting was that they
split the the concerns between those
with less experience and those with more
experience and you can see that quote
there at the bottom challenges around
tooling scale and model evolution
evaluation and deployment are more
important for engineers with a lot of
experience with AI and in terms of those
bullet points you can see that the last
one they around model evolution
evaluation and deployment is
particularly relevant to this this talks
title but having said that it's
important to note the amount of
entanglement there is in these sorts of
concepts if you have sort of these
pyramids of dependencies in terms of
best practices a few examples might be
if your model configuration isn't under
version control it's going to be a lot
harder for you to have truly
reproducible deterministic training of
your models and if you don't have that
sort of reproducible training in your
models then the effectiveness of the
canary release which I'm going to talk
about in a moment is going to be a lot
less so another example might be if you
don't understand the impacts of
staleness on your models then the
effectiveness of skew tests which saul
is going to be walking through it's
going to be also be reduced having said
that there are two key tests that I want
to highlight from the Google paper the
first is that make sure when you're
putting any new ML code into production
that you're doing a canary release first
and the second is that make sure you
understand the impact on quality of any
given change to a model before releasing
to production that's a lot of stuff to
remember all these checklists you know
different tests seem to think about
which is why I think reproducibility is
really worth highlighting because it's a
very useful North Star that you can
follow and you've got a definition on
there about reproducibility it's very
unlikely that if you truly have a system
where you can reproduce predictions from
the past that you don't also have a
quite well thought out
end-to-end pipeline effective
integration testing across the pipeline
good monitoring is just something that
will force you into adhering to a lot of
best practices so that's very powerful
but even if you can reproduce these
predictions from the past you're still
always going to come so that the most
nerve-wracking part of the journey which
is when you're putting out a model
update a new model and at this point
you're really worried because I mean a
is this model going to do what you
expect it to and be perhaps more
importantly have you made a mistake
particularly in a regulated environment
these are serious concerns we have a
spectrum of tests and techniques that we
can employ to help us address these
concerns on the left of this slide you
can see everything before production
these are your typical unit integration
acceptance tests etc and on the right we
have those things that you can be doing
when things are in production and we
want to highlight shadow mode which
Google calls dark launches and these are
really powerful because they kind of
straddle this divide between everything
before production and in production
because a shadow deployment doesn't
affect customers but it does work with
production data and code it's quite a
unique position and so you know people
say well why would you need shadow mode
I'm sure many of you and your companies
and projects have effective testing
environments you're staging
pre-production sandbox whatever you call
it but the brutal reality is that truly
replicating the production environment
in those test environments is extremely
challenging and this is for a myriad of
reasons you know you have these data
dependencies that you don't control
third parties who are changing
structures of documents seasonality
factors markets changing a lot of things
that to truly be a parity is a very
difficult challenge and whilst that's
certainly something you should strive
for a shadow mode deployment allows you
to control this risk so kind of what I'm
getting at here is this quote and for an
industry so obsessed with terminology
this is actually something that's still
a bit fuzzy you know a lot of companies
will read terms like deployment
releasing shipping just interchangeably
but you can actually
make a distinction and to be honest at
this point the terminology doesn't
matter what matters is the principle and
that's that you can have a deployment
where you don't affect customers and a
release where you do affect customers
and this is actually the the subtle
difference between a shadow deployment
and a canary release because in a canary
release you're releasing to a small
subset of customers there is any shadow
deployment no customers are affected ok
so let's get into it how do you do a
shadow deployment there are two ways the
first is at the application level so
here you have your incoming prediction
requests to your machine learning model
and you have the current model that
you're happy with and that will take in
these inputs and it will generate
predictions which are served back to
your clients users at the same time that
same input data is going to go to your
shadow model updates where the
predictions are also going to be
collected but they're just going to be
saved you won't return those to the
customer they're saved for analysis and
the way that you can do this this
branching in your code is it can be as
simple as an if-else statement but more
realistically you want to be using
feature flags if you have any concerns
about response times you should be doing
the shadow predictions asynchronously
and you need to think about your data
model because if you have meet the
ability to distinguish between any of
these shadow predictions and the live
prediction so this can be just making
the necessary changes in your database
schema or updating the fields in your
logging so that you can make that
distinction the second way you can do a
shadow deployment is at the
infrastructure level so here you have
that same incoming request for
prediction but then at the load balancer
level you're going to split those and
send the same request to two different
API endpoints or potentially two
different running services now this is a
little more challenging and requires a
more mature DevOps setup there are
things you need to think about you could
effectively be doubling the load on your
system if you have business events that
you need to
control carefully like customer creation
or customer billing you wanna make sure
you don't do that twice if you have
alerting and monitoring setup if you
have errors for your shadow deployment
you don't want to be paging people in
the middle of the night for those sorts
of errors so there are lots of things to
consider here and that does beg the
question when to use the infrastructure
shadow deployment few sort of scenarios
if you have some prototyping that you're
doing perhaps you've written your new
model in Python but you eventually plan
to rewrite in C++ or a faster language
you can prototype quickly at the
infrastructure level if you have an
application that is just a black box or
whatever reason it's too difficult to
update in the code then you can employ
this infrastructure level or even if
your feature flag system is so riddled
with technical debt that you're nervous
about adding yet more complexity there
sounds a bit crazy but you'd be
surprised
and in either case be it at the
application level or the infrastructure
level what you end up with these saved
sets of shadow predictions with the same
inputs that resulted in those
predictions and then you're ready to
begin your analysis and at this point
I'm going to hand over to Saleh who's
gonna walk you through that thank you
please hello everyone from me so in the
next 15 minutes or so I'm going to talk
about the test that we can do and
perhaps with shoot to where our models
are in shadow deployment so this here is
a diagram of an end-to-end machine
learning pipeline machine learning
system and as you can see there are a
lot of areas for tests that we can and
which hopefully would like to do so we
have on the first layer the all the
tests of a typical software development
application which are unit tests
integration tests and system monitoring
tests but machine learning pipelines
differ from traditional software
applications in that the behavior of the
machine learning pipeline is learned
from data is not implicit in the code
and also the inputs to the machine
learning pipeline is data and data
changes so there are a lot of more tests
that we want to do just to make sure
that the pipeline is behaving as we want
it to behave so we have of course a
battery of tests that we run even before
the model is decided to be put to be
sent to production so these are data
quality tests on the data that we're
going to use for training well then we
have the model performance tests and
also hopefully if we have a model in a
current system we want to compare how
the new model is is doing versus the
model that we have in place and once we
have we're happy that we want to deploy
our model so the machine learning
pipeline code that we are going to put
into production needs to be also unit
tested and integration test it just like
any piece of software once we're happy
to proceed and say our model is in
shadow mode we can start trying to
understand whether the inputs that we're
sending to the model are the ones that
we thought they were and whether a model
performance is the one that we also
expected and this includes tests for
data monitoring but also tastes of the
live data versus the training data and
as well as monitoring the model
predictions but why do we need so much
testing Chris already tapped into this
so I guess one of the key questions is
is the training data the one that we use
to produce the model representative of
the live data or the data that we're
going to score so that's one key
question other questions are around
feature dependencies are we getting the
features that we think we are getting
and just to give some examples and not
believe this hanging on the air so sink
for example if we are an insurance
company in the past there was no
electric cars and only recently cars a
slowly
electric cars are slowly coming into the
market so our story data has barely
nothing on fueling equals electric but
the system that we're running today
needs to accommodate for that so our
model is going to be getting this
feature
are we ready to tackle that so another
example is if we are a finance company
we defined affordability measures so
these are for example how much the ratio
between the debt and the income of the
customer so one
we can define that as total debt but
then we have a new head of risk and
desires and now that that is going to be
only the secure debt so this is
mortgages and car loans for example so
the distribution of the variable is
going to change dramatically and if it
is an input of our model we need to be
ready we need to be able to pick this up
so another thing that can happen which
also Chris mentioned briefly is that we
have data dependencies are models
consume features we can create those
features or maybe the group next door
creates those features or maybe the
features come even from third parties
what happens if all of a sudden we stop
receiving those features are we ready to
talk to that well to begin with we need
to be able to flag that now immediately
and finally we have the model
performance drift so how or when if at
all does our model lose the performance
or shows the decrease in the performance
so hopefully our tests are going to help
us find this out during shadow
deployment but also even after so
testing doesn't finish when we take our
model out of shadow it never finishes so
we should monitor our model throughout
its entire lifecycle as long as it's
calling our customers so please ensure
mentioned reproducibility so reproduce
ability is or is key so our model in
production should be ideally identical
to the one that we had in the research
environment so we can test this even
before putting the modern in shadow mode
while I have our model in the research
environment so what we want to do is to
measure that if we put the same data
through the machine learning pipeline in
research or in the development
environment we get exactly the same
output and before shadow mode we can
only do this with historic data and here
is when we are going to find out how
well our model replicates what we
discovered in research in theory it
should be identical in practice fairly
happens and there are a variety of
reasons why so one of them is that the
models many models require some element
of randomness to training that is
difficult to reproduce but by this stage
we hopefully understood the differences
where the models liebert were happy to
proceed and then we can put the model in
shadow mode and in shadow mode we can
repeat the
exercise but this time with live data
and if we obtain reproducibility in the
step before now we shouldn't find any
surprise but if we didn't measure the
produce ability before so this is the
time to do it while the model is in
shadow mode we need to be happy that the
two models are equivalent but this is
not the end of the story
our models can produce exactly identical
outputs given the same input and yet
they might give us very minimal business
value so why is that for a variety of
reasons first of all is how we receive
in the data that we thought we should be
receiving so we can test that by very
simple tests on the quality of the data
this test as I said they are very simple
it involves checking the inputs of the
variable so if we have categorical
variables and we are for example an
insurance company or a financial company
we generally ask our customers the
occupation and the occupation can take
one of four fields so either it is
self-employed employed unemployed or
part-time so we know that if that
variable is the input of our model it
can take one of those four categories if
it's taking an additional category we
have a problem so either we had a
feature change or maybe we had a bad
upstream or maybe we had a data outage
we need to be able to pick it up and we
need to be able to react to that finding
if we have other categorical variables
like the vant account of our customers
then don't take for values they take a
lot of values so it's difficult to
hard-code if not impossible but we can
learn those categories from the training
data we can create a schema we can store
those labels and when we find something
that is unusual again we are able to
flag it up and for numerical variables
so we usually know either from business
knowledge or from the training data that
the variable can come usually between
this minimum and that maximum value so
we can test whether the inputs come in
those in that range or if they come far
apart and we can even be a little bit
more their food and compare the million
or the mean of the variable to see if it
is similar and we're already starting to
measure a little bit the distributions
and what are we hoping to find out with
these tests well in this with this test
we're going to find out feature
dependencies are we getting the features
that we thought we should be getting and
if not we're going to find
out here another kind of test that we
want to do is to compare if the live
data is equivalent has the same
distributions of the training data so in
order to do this we do what here it's
called skewed tests but skewed tests can
take many forms and this is very basic
statistical test census it's not really
rocket science so we can compare for
example the proportion of missing data
in our variables or we can compare the
proportion of nonzero values in our
variables if the variable is super
skewed or if we have Spurs variables may
for example bag-of-words from text and
we can do this using the chi-square
distribution chi-square tests so a
chi-square will compare the proportion
of missing versus non missing data or
the proportion of 0 versus nonzero
values in our live data versus our
training data and it would tell us how
they were they are similar or not and
then while we're monitoring our mother's
life we can compare the distribution for
example of the customers that we scored
today versus the customer that was
called last week and if the distortions
are equivalent we should be able to pick
that up if the variables are numeric
numerical instead of yes what we want
what we can do is evaluate the
distributions with KS test score more of
smirnoff which compares the cumulative
distributions of the variable on
alternatively what we can do is we can
sort the data into buckets into bins and
we hope that the proportion of data in
each of those buckets for the training
data is the same as the proportion of
data in each of those buckets for the
live data and we can determine these
proportions with again the chi-square
test what are we hoping to identify with
this test well here we're going to
identify hopefully if the training data
was representative of the live data and
if it wasn't it can be one of many
things so either we didn't do a proper
collection of data in the past or market
changes and the markets do change so for
example if you're a financial
institution and in the past
were very conservative and offer loans
to premium customers but now he's
decided to take on more risk the
populations that you get today are not
the same as the populations that you got
in the past so that is something that
your model may or may not accommodate
but at least you can pick it up another
thing that can happen is for example if
you release an ad on television at 4
p.m. then you will get an influx of
customers with the characteristics of
the population that watch TV at 4 p.m.
that may or may not be similar than the
rest of your customers so we need to be
able to flag that out and then
understand what we want to do about it
and the other thing that we will be able
to pick up particularly with the missing
data proportion and the nonzero values
is whether there are data outages and
this does happen so it does happen that
credit agencies shut the systems for a
couple of hours not intentionally but it
does happen so if you are offering loans
based on a credit score what are you
going to do so either you have a fall
mark model or at least you need to stop
scoring until the data comes back live
again and last but also equally
important is we need to monitor the
predictions of our model is the model
predicting with the same distribution as
the one that we research that we did in
the research environment so again the
predictions are normally continuous
output if it is a probability or if it
is a regression so you can measure that
with a KS test and if it's not if you
want to test the classes you can do that
with a chi-square and what you want to
detect here is whether the distributions
in the research and the live environment
are similar and if not you can try and
understand that why it's happening
hopefully you have all the battery of
tests about the distribution of the data
that can tell you if they are not
different because the data is actually
not the same
and in this case during shadow mode we
may or may not be able to measure the
model performance and some patients were
able to know the rare outcome of the
prediction that we're making very soon
this that is the case we can evaluate
the performance with the typical
performance metric that we use but on
some of the cases like if we have models
for fraud if we have models for credit
risk we won't know the target until
three or four more down the line
and hopefully we don't want to keep our
mothers in shadow mode for so long so we
probably will release it without knowing
the outcome for the real performance but
because we continue monitoring
throughout the lifecycle eventually we
will know and we can start reducing say
quarterly reports about the performance
of the model so what do we hope to pick
up with this test
well performance drift how long is the
model keeping the performance that we
thought it was going to have in a
research environment so once we did all
these tests which we can assess in
shadow mode we are hopefully
understanding how representative our
data was if there were market changes if
there were feature changes and if the
model has the distribution that we
expect and then we are happy to release
this model out of shadow and continue
more iterating through the entire
pipeline so with this I'm going to
finish the talk thank you very much for
the attention if you fancy learning more
about more than deployment we have a
course on udemy that you can check and
you can reach elect reason me in
LinkedIn also join data thank you
[Applause]
we now have five minutes with questions
so if you do have a question please
yes so the kiyose tests are designed to
monitor the frequency distribution of
the data and then if the distribution
changes it will send a flag to us and
then we can check but how we react to
that flag depends on the situation so we
see a flag and then we ask a question
and then they say no we released another
placement fantastic ignore that flag but
on other occasions we see the flag what
happened we don't know you contact the
credit agency oh yes we change the
definition of affordability so that is
the problem now we need to start looking
closely the performance of the model is
it the one that is desired if it is all
good if not we need to make a decision
do we represent replace the model or
yeah so it's the monitoring is just to
make us aware that changes are occurring
so you're referring to the the sort of
tooling around versioning and data that
we were showing earlier in the talk yeah
I mean it sounds like you're talking
from - it's a real experience there yeah
I mean you know Knebel you're going to
have to do a bit of trial and error
because because we were saying this is
one of the the challenging things as we
don't have this sort of gold standard
stack or combination of tools that are
the go-to once but recently I've been
playing around with data science version
control DBC I recommend checking that up
yeah absolutely I mean you basically it
depends on your risk profile for Egypt
and any of those systems so if your
production system that's only serving
one sales guy goes wrong and that
doesn't have a big business impact then
for sure this this amount of testing is
going to be overkill but on the other
hand if it's something that might have
regulatory impact or an effect on
people's livelihoods or something really
serious then maybe it may be it is
necessary so it's kind of a business
call
[Applause]